the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay welcome back you know it's that
time a term when we're all kind of doing
this so let me see if I can get a few
smiles by simply noting to you that two
weeks from today is the last class
should be worth at least a little bit of
a smile right professor Guttag is
smiling he likes that idea you're almost
there
what are we doing for the last couple of
lectures we're talking about linear
regression and I just want to remind you
this was the idea of I have some
experimental data case of a spring where
I put different weights on a measure
displacements and regression was giving
us a way of deducing a model to fit that
data in some cases it was easy we knew
for example it was going to be a linear
model we found the best line that would
fit data in some cases we said we could
use validation to actually let us
explore to find the best model it would
fit it whether it's a linear or cubic or
sorry linear a quadratic ax cubed some
higher order thing so we be using that
to deduce something about a model that's
a nice segue into the topic for the next
three lectures the last big topic of the
class which is machine learning and I'm
going to argue you can debate whether
that's actually an example of learning
but it has many of the elements that we
want to talk about when we talk about
machine learning so as always there's a
reading assignment chapter 22 of the
book gives you a good start on this and
it will follow up with other pieces and
I want to start by basically outlining
what we're going to do and I'm going to
begin by saying as I'm sure you're aware
this is a huge topic I've listed just
five subjects in course six that all
focus on machine learning and that
doesn't include other subjects we're
learning as a central part so natural
language processing computational
biology computer vision robotics all
rely today heavily on machine learning
and you'll see those in those subjects
as well so we're not going to compress
five subjects into three lectures but
what we are going to do is give you the
introduction we're going to start by
talking about the basic concepts of
machine learning the idea of having
samples and how do you talk about
features representing those examples how
do you measure distances between them
and use the notion of distance to try
and group similar things together as a
way of doing machine learning and we're
going to look as a consequence of two
different standard ways of doing
learning one we call classification
methods example we're going to see there
something called K nearest neighbor in
the second class called clustering
methods classification works well when I
have what we would call label data I
know labels on my examples and I'm going
to use that to try and define classes
that I can learn and clustering working
well when I don't have label data and
we'll see what that means in a couple of
minutes but we're going to give you an
early view of this unless professor
Guttag changes his mind we're probably
not going to show you the current really
sophisticated machine learning methods
like convolutional neural nets or deep
learning things you'll read about in the
news but you're going to get a sense of
what's behind those by looking at what
we do when we talk about learning
algorithms before I do it I want to
point out to you just how prevalent this
is and I'm going to admit with my gray
hair I started working in AI in 1975
when machine learning was a pretty
simple thing to do and it's been
fascinating to watch over 40 years the
change and if you think about it just
think about where you see it alphago
machine learning based system from
Google the beat a world-class level go
player chess has already been computed
for a while go now belongs to computers
best go players in the world or
computers I'm sure many of you use
Netflix any recommendation system
Netflix Amazon pick your favorite uses a
machine learning algorithm to suggest
things for you in fact you've probably
seen it on Google right the ads that pop
up on Google are coming from a machine
learning algorithm that's looking at
your preferences scary thought drug
discovery character recognition the post
office does character recognition of
handwritten characters using a machine
learning algorithm in a computer vision
system behind it you probably don't know
this company it's actually an MIT
spin-off called to Sigma it's a hedge
fund in New York they heavily use AI a
machine learning techniques in
years ago their fund returned a 56%
return I wish I'd invested in the fund I
don't have the kinds of millions you
need but that's an impressive return 56%
return on your money in one year last
year they didn't do quite as well but
they do extremely well using machine
learning techniques Siri
another great MIT company called mobile
I that does computer vision systems with
a heavy machine learning component that
is used in assistive driving and will be
used in completely autonomous driving it
will do things like kick in your brakes
if your closing too fast on the car in
front of you which is going to be really
bad for me because I Drive like a like a
Bostonian and it would be kicking in
constantly face recognition Facebook
uses this many other systems do to
recognize both detect and recognize
faces IBM Watson cancer diagnosis these
are all just examples of machine
learning being used everywhere and it
really is I've only picked nine so what
is it I'm going to make an obnoxious
statement you're now used to that I'm
going to claim that you know you could
argue that almost every computer program
learns something but the level of
learning really varies a lot so if you
think back to the first lecture in six
triple oh one we showed you Newton's
method for computing square roots and
you could argue you have to stretch it
but you could argue that that method
learn something about how to compute
square roots in fact you could
generalize it to roots of any order
power but it really didn't learn I
really had to program it and I think
about last week when we talked about
linear regression that starts to feel a
little bit more like a learning
algorithm because what did we do we gave
you a set of data points mass
displacement data points and then we
showed you how the computer could
essentially fit a curve to that data
point and it was in some sense learning
a model for that data that it could then
use to predict behavior in other
situations and that's getting closer to
what we would like when we think about a
machine learning algorithm we'd like to
have program that can learn
from experience something that it can
then use to deduce new facts now it's
been a problem in AI for a very long
time and I'd love this quote as from a
gentleman named art Samuel 1959 is the
quote in which he says his definition of
machine learning it's the field of study
that gives computers the ability to
learn without being explicitly
programmed and I think many people would
argue he wrote the first such program it
learned from experience in his case it
played checkers kind of shows you how
the field is progressed at we started
with checkers we got the chess we now do
go but it played checkers it beat
national level players most importantly
it learned to improve its methods by
watching how it did in games and then
inferring something to change what it
thought about as it did that Samuel did
a bunch of other things I've just
highlighted one you may see in a
follow-on course he invented what's
called alpha-beta pruning which is a
really useful technique for doing search
but the idea is how can we have the
computer learn without being explicitly
programmed in one way to think about
this is to think about the difference
between how we would normally program
and what we would like from a scene
learning algorithm normal programming I
know you're not convinced there's such a
thing as normal programming but if you
think of traditional programming what's
the process I write a program that I
input to the computer so that it can
then take data and produce some
appropriate output and the square root
finder really sits there right I wrote
code for using Newton method to find a
square root and then it gave me the
problem or the process of given any
number I'll give you the square root but
if you think about what we did last time
it was a little different and in fact in
a machine learning approach the idea is
that I'm going to give the computer
output I'm going to give it examples of
what I want the program to do labels on
data characterizations of different
classes of things and what I want the
computer to do is given that
characterization of output and data I
want it that machine learning algorithm
to actually produce for me a program a
program that I can then use
to infer new information about things
and that creates if you like a really
nice loop where I can have the machine
learning algorithm learn the program
which I can then use to solve some other
problem that would be really great if we
could do it and as I suggested that
curve fitting algorithm is a simple
version of that it learned a model for
the data which I could then use to label
any other instances of the date or
predict what I would see in terms of
spring displacement as I changed the
masses so that's the kind of idea we're
going to explore if we want to learn
things we could also ask so how do you
learn and how should a computer learn
well for you as a human there are a
couple of possibilities this is the
boring one this is the old-style way of
doing your right memorize facts memorize
as many facts as you can and hope that
we ask you on the final exam instances
of those facts as opposed to some other
facts you haven't memorized this is if
you think way back to the first lecture
an example of declarative knowledge
statements of truth memorize as many as
you can have Wikipedia in your back
pocket a better way to learn is to be
able to infer to deduce new information
from old and if you think about this
this gets closer to what we called
imperative knowledge ways to deduce new
things now in the first cases we built
that in when we wrote that program to do
square roots but what we like in a
learning algorithm is to have much more
like that generalization idea we're
interested in extending our capabilities
to write programs that can infer useful
information from implicit patterns in
the data so not something explicitly
built-in like that comparison of weights
and displacements but actually implicit
patterns in the data and have the
algorithm figure out what those patterns
are and use those to generate a program
you can use to infer new data about
objects about spring displacements
whatever it is you're trying to do ok so
the idea then the basic paradigm that
we're going to see is we're going to
give system some training data some
survey shion's we did that last time
with just the spring displacements we're
going to then try and have the way to
figure out how do we write code how do
we write a program a system that will
infer something about the process that
generated the data and then from that we
want to be able to use that to make
predictions about things we haven't seen
before so again I want to drive home
this point if you think about it the
spring example fit that model I gave you
a set of data spatial deviations
relative to massive places for different
masses how far did the spring move
I then inferred something about the
underlying process the first case I said
I know it's linear but let me figure out
what the actual linear equation is
what's the spring constant associated
with it and based on that result I got a
piece of code I could use to predict new
displacements so it's got all of those
elements training data into inference
engine and then the ability to use that
to make new predictions but that's a
very simple kind of learning setting so
the more common one is what I'm going to
use as an example which is when I give
you a set of examples those examples
have some data associated with them some
features and some labels that vary each
example I might say this is a particular
kind of thing this other one's another
kind of thing and what I want to do is
figure out how to do inference on
labeling new things so it's not just
what's the displacement of the mass it's
actually a label and I'm going to use
one of my favorite examples I'm a big
New England Patriots fan if you're not
my apologies but I'm going to use
football players so I'm going to show
you in a second I'm going to give you a
set of examples of football players the
label is the position they play in the
data well it could be lots of things
we're going to use height and weight but
what we want to do is then see if how
would we come up with the way of
characterizing the implicit pattern of
how does weight and height predict the
kind of position this player could play
and then come when you come up with an
algorithm will predict the position of
new players we do the draft for next
year where do we want them to play
that's the paradigm set of observations
potentially they will potentially not
think about how do we do inference to
find a model and then how do we use that
model to make predictions what we're
going to see and we're going to see
multiple examples today is that that
learning can be done in one of two very
broad ways the first one is called
supervised learning in that case for
every new example I give you as part of
the training data I have a label on it I
know the kind of thing it is and what
I'm going to do is look for how do I
find a rule that would predict the label
associated with unseen input based on
those examples it's supervised because I
know what the labeling is second kind if
this is supervised the obvious other one
is called unsupervised in that case I'm
just going to give you a bunch of
examples but I don't know the labels
associated with them I'm going to just
try and find what are the natural ways
to group those examples together into
different models in some cases I may
know how many models are there in some
cases I may want to just say what's the
best grouping I can find okay what I'm
going to do today is not a lot of code I
was expecting cheers for that John but I
didn't get them not a lot of code what
I'm going to do is show you basically
the intuitions behind doing this
learning I'm going to start with my New
England Patriots example so here are
some data points about current Patriots
players and I've got two kinds sorry up
positions I've got receivers and I have
linemen and each one is just labeled by
the name the height in inches and the
weight in pounds okay five of each if I
plot those on a two-dimensional plot
this is what I get okay no big deal what
am I trying to do I'm trying to learn
are there characteristics that
distinguish the two classes from one
another and in the unlabeled case all I
have are just a set of examples so what
I want to do is decide what makes two
players similar with the goal of seeing
can I separate this distribution into
two or more natural groups similar as a
distance measure says how do I take two
examples with values or features
associated when decide how far apart are
they and in the unlabeled case the
way to do it is to say if I know that
there are at least K groups there in
this case I'm going to tell you there
are two different groups there how could
I decide how best to cluster things
together so that all the examples in one
group are close to each other all the
examples in the other group are close to
each other and they're reasonably far
apart there are many ways to do it I'm
going to show you one it's a very
standard way and it works basically as
follows if all I know is that there are
two groups there I'm going to start by
just picking two examples as my exemplar
z' pick them at random actually at
random is not great I don't want to pick
too close to each other I'm going to try
and pick them far apart but I picked two
examples as my exemplars and for all the
other examples in the training data I
say which one is it closest to what I'm
going to try and do is create clusters
with the property that the distances
between all of the examples of that
cluster are small the average distance
is small and see if I can find clusters
it gets the average distance for both
cluster as small as possible this
algorithm works by picking two examples
clustering all the other examples by
simply saying put it in the group which
into which it's closest to that example
once I've got those clusters I'm going
to find the median element of that group
not mean but meeting what's the one
closest to the center and treat those as
my exemplars and repeat the process and
I'll just do it either some number of
times or until I don't get any change in
the process so it's clustering based on
distance and we'll come back to distance
in a second so here's what would happen
with my football players if I just did
this based on weight there's the natural
dividing line and it kind of makes sense
right these three are obviously
clustered and again it's just on this
axis they're all down here these seven
are at a different place there's a
natural dividing line there if I were to
do it based on height not as clean this
is what my algorithm came up with as the
best dividing line here meaning that
these four game just based on this axis
are close together these six are close
together but it's not nearly as clean
and that's part of the issue we'll look
at us
how do I find the best clusters if I use
both height and weight I get that
which is actually kind of nice right
those three cluster together they're
near each other in terms of just
distance in the plane those seven are
near each other there's a nice natural
dividing line through here and in fact
that gives me a classifier this line is
the equidistant line between the Centers
of those two clusters meaning any point
on along this line is the same distance
to the center of that group as it is to
that group and so any new example if
it's above the line I would say gets
that label if it's below the line gets
that label in a second we'll come back
to look at how do we measure the
distances but the idea here is pretty
simple I want to find groupings near
each other and far apart from the other
group now suppose I actually knew the
labels on these are players I shouldn't
call them objects they're people these
players these are the receivers those
are the linemen and for those of you or
football pan fans you can figure out
right those are the two tight ends
they're much bigger
I think that's Bennett and that's Gronk
if you're really a big Patriots fan but
those are tight ends those are wide
receivers and it's going to come back in
a second but there are the labels now
what I want to do is say if I could take
advantage of knowing the labels how
would I divide these groups up and
that's kind of easy to see basic idea in
this case is if I've got labelled groups
in that feature space what I want to do
is find a sub surface that naturally
divides that space now subsurface it's a
fancy word it says in the
two-dimensional case I don't want to
know what's the best line if I can find
a single line that separates all the
examples with one label from all the
examples of the second label we'll see
that if the examples are well separated
this is easy to do and it's great but in
some cases it's going to be more
complicated because some of the examples
may be very close to one another and
that's going to raise a problem that you
saw a last lecture I want to avoid
overfitting I don't want to create a
really complicated surface to separate
things and so we may have to tolerate a
few incorrectly labeled things if we
can't pull it out
and as you already figured out in this
case with the labeled data there's the
best fitting line right there anybody
over 280 pounds is going to be a great
lineman anybody under 280 pounds is more
likely to be a receiver okay
so I've got two different ways of trying
to think about doing this labeling I'm
going to come back to both of them in a
second now suppose I add in some new
data I want to label new instances now
these are actually players of a
different position these are running
backs but I say all I know about is
receivers and linemen I get these two
new data points I'd like to know are
they more likely to be a receiver or
alignment and there's the data for these
two gentlemen so if I go back to now
plotting them oh you notice one of the
issues so there are my linemen the red
ones are my receivers the two black dots
are the two running backs notice right
here it's going to be really hard to
separate those two examples from one
another they are so close to each other
and that's going to be one of the things
we have to trade off but if I think
about using what I learned as a
classifier with unlabeled data there
were my two clusters now you see I've
got an interesting example this new
example I would say is clearly more like
a receiver than alignment but that one
there unclear almost exactly lies along
that dividing line between those two
clusters and that would either say I
want to rethink the clustering or I want
to say you know what as I know maybe
there aren't two clusters here maybe
there are three and I want to classify
them a little differently so I'll come
back to that on the other hand if I'd
use the labeled data there was my
dividing line this is really easy both
of those new examples are clearly below
the dividing line they are clearly
examples that I would categorize as
being more like receivers than they are
like linemen and I know it's a football
example if you don't like football pick
another example but you get the sense of
why I can use the data in the labeled
case in the unlabeled case to come up
with different ways building the
Buster's so what we're going to do over
the next two and a half lectures is look
at how can we write code to learn that
way of separating things out we're going
to learn models based on unlabeled data
that's the case where I don't know what
the labels are by simply trying to find
ways to cluster things together nearby
and then use the clusters to assign
labels to new data and we're going to
learn models by looking at labeled data
and seeing how do we best come up with a
way of separating with a line or a plane
or a collection of lines examples from
one group from examples of the other
group with the acknowledgment that we
want to avoid overfitting we don't want
to create a really complicated system
and as a consequence we're going to have
to make some trade-offs between what we
call false positives and false negatives
but the resulting classifier can then
label any new data by just deciding
where you are with respect to that
separating line so here's what you're
going to see over the next two and a
half lectures every machine learning
method has five essential components we
need to decide what's the training data
and how are we going to evaluate the
success of that system I've already seen
some examples of that we need to decide
how are we going to represent each
instance that we're giving it I happen
to choose height and weight for football
players but I might have been better off
to pick average speed or I don't know
arm length something else how do I
figure out what are the right features
and associated with that how do I
measure distances between those features
how do I decide what's close and what's
not close maybe it should be different
in terms of weight versus height for
example I need to make that decision and
those are the two things we're going to
show you examples up to date how to go
through that starting next week
professor Guttag is going to show you
how you take those and actually start
building more detailed versions of
measuring clustering measuring
similarities to find an objective
function that you want to minimize to
decide what is the best cluster to use
and then what is the best optimization
method you want to use to learn that
model so let's start talking about
features I've got a set of examples
labeled or not
I need to decide what is that about
those examples that's useful to use when
I want to decide what's close to another
thing or not and one of the problems is
if it was really easy it would be really
easy features don't always capture what
you want I'm going to belabor that
football analogy but why did I pick
height and weight because it was easy to
find but what is you know if you work
for the New England Patriots what is the
thing that you really look for when
you're asking what's the right feature
it's probably some other combination
things so you as a designer have to say
what are the features I want to use I
quote by the way it's from one of the
great statisticians of the 20th century
which I think captures it well so
feature engineering as you as a
programmer comes down to deciding both
what are the features I want to measure
in that vector that I'm going to put
together and how do I decide relative
ways to weight it so John and Anna and I
could have made our torch or this on
Troy wrong terms on our job this term
really easy if we had sat down at the
beginning of the term and said you know
we've taught this course many times
we've got data from I don't know John
thousands of students probably over this
time let's just build a little learning
algorithm it takes a set of data and
predicts your final grade you don't have
to come class don't have to go through
all the problems as we'll just predict
your final grade wouldn't that be nice
being make our job a little easier and
you may or may not like that idea but I
could think about predicting that great
now why am I telling this example I was
trying to see if I could get a few
smiles I saw a couple of them there but
think about the features what would I
measure I shall put this on John because
it's his idea what would he measure well
GPA is probably not a bad predictor
performance you do well in other classes
you're likely to do well in this class
I'm going to use this one very carefully
prior programming experience is at least
a predictor but it is not a perfect
predictor those of you haven't
programmed before in this class you can
still do really well in this class but
it's an indication that you've seen
other programming languages on the other
hand I don't believe in astrology so I
don't think the month in which you're
born the austra astrological sign under
which you were born it has probably
anything to do with how
well you'd program I doubt that I color
has anything to do with how well you
program you get the idea some features
matter others don't
now I could just throw all the features
in and hope that the machine learning
algorithm sorts out those it wants to
keep from those it doesn't but I remind
you that idea of overfitting if I do
that there is the danger that it will
find some correlation between birth
month I color and GPA and that's going
to lead to a conclusion that we really
don't like by the way in case you're
worried I can assure you that stew
shmall in the Dean of Admissions
department does not use machine learning
to pick you he actually looks at a whole
bunch of things because it's not easy to
replace him with a machine yep all right
so what this says is we need to think
about how do we pick the features and
mostly what we're trying to do is to
maximize something called the
signal-to-noise ratio maximize those
features that carry the most information
and remove the ones that don't so I want
to show you an example of how you might
think about this
I want to label reptiles I want to come
up with a way of labeling animals as are
they a reptile or not and I give you a
single example with a single example you
can't really do much but from this
example I know that a cobra is it lays
eggs it has scales it's poisonous its
cold-blooded it has no legs and it's a
reptile so I could say my model of a
reptile is well I'm not certain I don't
have enough data yet but if I give you a
second example and it also happens to be
egg-laying have scales poisonous
cold-blooded node lakes
there's my model right perfectly
reasonable model whether I design it our
machine learning algorithm would do it
says if all of these are true label it
as a reptile okay and now I give you a
boa constrictor ah it's a reptile but it
doesn't fit the model and in particular
it's not egg-laying and it's not
poisonous so I've got to refine the
model or the algorithms got to refine
the model and this I want to remind you
is looking at the feature so I started
out with five features this doesn't fit
so probably what I should do is reduce
it I'm going to look at scales I'm going
to look at cold-blooded I'm going to
look at legs that captures all three
examples again if you think about this
in terms of clustering all three of them
would fit with that okay
now I'll give you another example
chicken I don't think it's a reptile in
fact I'm pretty sure it's not a reptile
and it nicely still fits this model
right because while it has scales which
you may not realize it's not
cold-blooded and it has legs so it is a
negative example that reinforces the
model sounds good and now I'll give you
an alligator it's a reptile
you know fudge right it doesn't satisfy
the model because well it does have
scales and it is cold-blooded it has
legs I'm almost done with the example
but you see the point again I've got to
think about how do I refine this and I
could by saying all right let's make it
a little more complicated have scales
cold-blooded zero or four legs I'm going
to say it's a reptile I'll give you the
dart frog not a reptiles and amphibian
and that's nice because it still
satisfies it so it's an example outside
of the cluster that says no scales not
cold-blooded but happens have four legs
it's not a reptile that's good and then
I give you a half to Python right I mean
there has to be a Python in here oh come
on at least groan at me when I say that
there has to be a Python here and I give
you that in a salmon and now I am in
trouble because look at scales look at
cold-blooded look at legs
I can't separate them on those features
there's no way to come up with a way
that will correctly say that the Python
is a reptile and the salmon is not and
so there's no easy to way to add in that
rule and probably my best thing is to
simply go back to just two features
scales and cold blooded and basically
say if something has scales and it's
cold-blooded I'm going to call it a
reptile
if it doesn't have both of those I'm
going to say it's not a reptile it won't
be perfect it's going to incorrectly
label the salmon but I've made a design
choice here that's important and the
design choice is that I will have no
false negatives what that means is
there's not going to be any instance of
something that's not a reptile that I'm
going to call a reptile I may have some
false positives so I did that the wrong
way if false negative says everything
that's not a reptile I'm going to say
I'm going to categorize that direction I
may have some false positives in that I
may have a few things that I will
incorrectly labeled as a reptile and in
particular whoops sorry salmon is going
to be an instance of that this trade-off
of false positives and false negatives
is something that we worry about as we
think about it because there's no
perfect way in many cases separate of
the data and if you think back to my
example of the New England Patriots that
running back on that wide receiver were
so close together in height weight there
is no way I'm going to be able to
separate them apart and I just have to
be willing to decide how many false
positives or false negatives do I want
to tolerate once I figured out what
features to use which is good then I
have to decide about distance how do I
compare to feature vectors they're going
to say vector because there be multiple
dimensions to it how do I decide how to
compare them because I want to use the
distances to figure out either how to
group things together or how to find a
dividing line that separates things
apart so one of the things I have to
decide is which features I also have to
decide the distance and finally I may
want to decide how to weigh relative
importance of different dimensions in
the feature vector some may be more
valuable than others in making that
decision and I want to show you an
example of that so let's go back to my
animals I've got I started off with a
feature vector that actually had five
dimensions to it it was when egg-laying
cold-blooded has scales I forget what
the other one was a number of legs so
one of the ways I could think about this
is saying I've got four binary features
and one integer feature associated with
each animal and one way to learn to
separate out reptiles from non reptiles
is
to measure the distance between pairs of
examples and use that distance to decide
what's near each other and what's not
and as you said before it lead to be
used to cluster things or to find a
classifier surface that separates them
so here's a simple way to do it for each
of these examples I'm going to just let
true be one false be zero so the first
four are either zeros or ones and the
last one is the number of legs and now I
could say all right how do I measure
distances between animals or anything
else about these kinds of feature
vectors here we're going to use
something called the Minkowski metric or
the Minkowski difference given two
vectors and a power P we basically take
the absolute value of the difference
between each of the components of the
vector raise it to the peeth power take
the sum and take the piece root of that
so let's do the two obvious examples if
P is equal to one I just measure the
absolute distance between each component
add them up and that's my distance it's
called the Manhattan metric the one
you've seen more than we saw last time
if P is equal to two this is this is
Euclidean distance right it's the sum of
the squares of the differences of the
components take the square root take the
square root because it makes it have
certain properties of a distance that's
the sorry that's the Euclidean distance
so now if I want to measure difference
between these two here's the question is
this circle closer to the star or closer
to the cross unfortunately I put the
answer up here but it differs depending
on the metric I use right Euclidean
distance well that's square root of 2
times 2 so it's about 2.8 and that's 3
so in terms of just standard distance in
the plane we would say that these two
are closer than those to our Manhattan
distance why is it called that because
you can only walk along the avenues and
the streets Manhattan distance would
basically say this is 1 2 3 4 units away
this is 1 2 3 units away and under
Manhattan distance this is closer this
pairing is closer than that pairing is
now you're used to thinking Euclidean
we're going to use that but this is
going to be important when we think
about how are we comparing distances
between these different pieces so
typically will use the Euclidean we're
going to see Manhattan actually has some
value so if I go back to my three
examples boy that's a gross slide isn't
it but there we go
rattlesnake boa constrictor and dart
frog there's a representation I can ask
what's the distance between them in the
handout for today we've given you a
little piece of code that would do that
and if I actually run through it I get
actually a nice little result here are
the distances between those vectors
using Euclidean metric whoops sorry I'm
going to come back then but you can see
the two snakes nicely are reasonably
close to each other whereas the dart
frog is a fair distance away from that
nice right that's a nice separation it
says there's a difference between these
two okay now I throw in the alligator
sounds like a Dungeons and Dragons game
I throw in the alligator and I want to
do the same comparison and I don't get
nearly as nice a result because now it
says as before the two snakes are close
to each other but it says that the dart
frog and the alligator are much closer
under this measurement then either them
is to the other and to remind you right
the alligator and the two snakes I would
like to be close to one another and a
distance away from the Frog because I'm
trying to classify reptiles versus not
so what happened here well this is a
place where the feature engineering is
going to be important because in fact
the alligator differs from the Frog in
three features but and only in two
features from say the boa constrictor
but one of those features is the number
of legs and their while on the binary
axes the difference is between a 0 & 1
here it can between can be between 0 & 4
so that is weighing the distance a lot
more than we would like the legs
dimension is too large if you like how
would I fix this this is actually I
would argue a natural place to you
is Manhattan distance why should I think
that the difference in the number of
legs or the number of legs difference is
more important than whether it has
scales or not why should I think that
measuring that distance Euclidean wise
make sense they are really completely
different measurements and in fact I'm
not going to do it but if I ran
Manhattan metric on this it would get
the alligator much closer to the snakes
exactly because it differs only in two
features not three the other way I could
fix it would be to say I'm letting too
much weight be associated with the
difference in the number of legs so
let's just make it a binary feature
either it doesn't have legs or it does
have legs run the same classification
and now you see the snakes and the
alligator are all close to each other
whereas the dart frog not as far away as
well as before but there's a pretty
natural separation especially using that
number between what's my point
choice of features matters throwing too
many features in may in fact give us
some overfitting and in particular
deciding the weights that I want on
those features has a real impact and you
as a designer a programmer have a lot of
influence and how you think about using
those so feature engineering really
matters how you pick the features what
you use is going to be important okay
the last piece of this then is we're
going to look at some examples where we
give you data got features associated
with them we're going to in some cases
have them labeled in other cases not and
we know how now to think about how do we
measure distances between them John
sorry the scales that not though thank
you John now I did take that back I did
not mean to say waste of features I
meant to say the scale of the dimension
is going to be important to thank you
for the for the amplification and
correction you're absolutely right and
we're going to see next time we're going
to use weights a different way so
rephrase it block that out of your mind
we're going to talk about scales and the
scale on the axes is being important
here and we already said we're going to
look at two different kinds of learning
labeled and unlabeled clustering and
classifying and I want to just finish up
by showing you two examples of that how
we would think about them
algorithmically and we'll look at them
in more detail next time as we look at
it I want to remind you the things that
are going to be important to you how do
I measure distance between examples
what's the right way to design that what
is the right set of features to use in
that vector and then what constraints do
I want to put on the model in the case
of unlabeled data how do I decide how
many clusters I want to have because I
can give you a really easy way to do
clustering I would give you a hundred
examples I say build 100 clusters every
example is this own cluster distance is
really good it's really close to itself
but it does allow the job of labeling
things on it so I have to think about
how do I decide how many clusters what's
the complexity of that separating
service how do I basically avoid the
overfitting problem which I don't want
to have so just remind you we've already
seen a little version of this the
clustering method this is a standard way
to do it simply repeating what we had on
an earlier slide I want to cluster it
into groups I start by saying how many
clusters am I looking for pick an
example as take as my early
representation for every other example
in the training data put it to the
closest cluster once I've got those find
the median repeat the process and that
led to that separation now once I've got
it I like to validate it and in fact I
should have said this better those two
clusters came without looking at the the
two black dots once I put the black dots
in I'd like to validate how well does
this really work in that
example there is really not very
encouraging it's too close so that's a
natural place to say okay what if I did
this with three clusters that's what I
get I like that right that has a really
nice cluster up here fact that the
algorithm didn't know the labeling is
irrelevant there's a nice grouping of
five there's a nice grouping of four and
there's a nice grouping of three in
between and in fact if I looked at the
distance the average distance between
examples in each of these clusters it is
much tighter than in that example and so
that what sorry that leads to then the
question of should I look for four
clusters question please yeah the
question is is the overlap between the
two clusters a problem no I just drew it
here so I could let you see where those
pieces are but in fact if you like the
boundary is that the center is there
those three points are all closer to
that Center than they are to that Center
so the fact that they overlap so good
question is just the way I happen to
draw them I should really draw these not
as circles but as some little bit more
convoluted surface okay having done
three I could say should I look for four
well those points down there as I've
already said are an example where it's
going to be hard to separate them out
and I don't want to over fit because the
only way to separate those out is the
kind of is going to be to come up with a
really convoluted cluster which I don't
like right let me finish with showing
you one other example from the other
direction which is suppose I give you
labeled examples so again the goal is
I've got features associated with each
example they're going to have multiple
dimensions on it but I also know the
label associated with them and I want to
learn what is the best way to come up
with a rule that will let me take new
examples and assign them to the right
group number of ways to do this you can
simply say I'm looking for the simplest
surface that will separate those
examples in my football case that we're
in the plane what's the best line that
separates them which turns out to be
easy I might look for a more complicated
surface and we're going to see an
example in a second where maybe it's a
sequence of line segments that separates
them out because there's not just one
line
that does the separation as before I
want to be careful if I make it too
complicated I may get a really good
separator but I over fit to the data and
you're going to see next time I'm going
to highlight it here there's a third way
which will lead to them almost the same
kind of result called K nearest
neighbors and the idea here is I've got
a set of labeled data and what I'm going
to do is for every new example say find
the K say the five closest labeled
examples and take a vote if three out of
five or four out of five of five out of
five of those labels are the same I'm
going to say it's part of that group and
if I have less than that I'm going to
leave it as unclassified and that's a
nice way of actually thinking about how
to learn them and let me just finish by
showing you an example and I won't use
football players on this one I'll use a
different example I'm going to give you
some voting data I think this is
actually simulated data but these are a
set of voters in the United States with
their preference they tend to vote
Republican they tend to vote Democrat
and the two categories are their age and
how far away they live from Boston
whether those are relevant or not I
don't know but they're just two things
are going to use to classify them and
I'd like to say how would I fit a curve
to separate those two classes I'm going
to keep half the data to test I'm going
to use half the data to train so if this
is my training data I could say what's
the best line that separates these I
don't know about best but here are two
examples this solid line has the
property that all the Democrats are on
one side everything on the other side is
a Republican but there are some
Republicans on this side of the line I
can't find a line that completely
separates these as I did with the
football players but there's a decent
line to separate them here's another
candidate that dash line has the
property that on the right side you've
got boy I don't think this is deliberate
John right but on the right side you've
got almost all Republicans seems like
perfectly appropriate one Democrat but
there's a pretty good separation there
and on the left side you've got a mix of
things but most of the Democrats are on
the left side of that line all right
the fact that left and right correlates
with distance from
Boston's completely irrelevant here but
it has a nice punch to it but not
accidental thank you all right so now
the question is how would I evaluate
these how do I decide which one's better
and I'm simply going to show you very
quickly some examples first one is to
look at it's called the confusion matrix
what does that mean it says for this one
of these classifiers for example the
solid line here are the predictions
based on the solid line of whether they
would be more likely to be Democrat or
Republican and here's the actual label
same thing for the dashed line and that
diagonal is important because those are
the correctly labeled results write it
correctly in the dashed line case solid
line case gets all of the correct
labelings of the Democrats he gets half
of the Republicans right but it has some
where it's actually a Republican but it
labels it as a Democrat that we'd like
to be really large and in fact it leads
to a natural measure called the accuracy
which is just to go back to that we say
that these are true positives meaning I
labeled it as being an instance and it
really is these are true negatives I
label it as not being an instance and it
really isn't and then these are the
false positives I label that as being in
instances or not and these are the false
negatives I label it as not being an
instance and it is and an easy way to
measure it is to look at the correct
labels over all of the labels the true
positives and the true negatives the
ones I got right and in that case both
models come up with a value of 0.7 so
which one's better well I should
validate that and I want to do that in a
second by looking at other data we could
also ask could we find something with
less training error this is only getting
70% right not great well here's a more
complicated model and this is where you
start getting worried about overfitting
now what I've done is I've come up with
a sequence of lines that separate them
so everything above this line I'm going
to say is a Republican everything below
this line I'm going to say is a Democrat
so I'm avoiding that one I'm avoiding
that one I'm still capturing many of the
same things and in this case
twelve true positives thirteen true
negatives and only five false positives
and that's kind of nice you can see the
five it's those five red ones down there
its accuracy is 0.833 and now if I apply
that to the test data I get an okay
result as an accuracy of about point six
I could use this idea to try and
generalize I say could I come up with a
better model and you're going to see
that next time there could be other ways
in which I measure this and I want to
use this as the last example another
good measure we use is called PPV
predictive positive it's right positive
predictive value which is how many true
positives do I come up with out of all
the things I labeled positively and in
the solid model in the dashed line I get
values about point five seven the
complex model on the training data is
better in the in the testing data is
even stronger and finally two other
examples are called sensitivity and
specificity sensitivity basically tells
you what percentage did I correctly find
and specificity said what percentage did
I correctly reject and I show you this
because this is where the trade-off
comes in I could make sense that
sensitivity is how many did I correctly
label out of those that I both correctly
labeled incorrectly labeled as being
negative how many of them did I
correctly labeled as being the kind that
I want I can make sensitivity one label
everything is the thing I'm looking for
great everything's correct but the
specificity will be zero because I'll
have a bunch of things incorrectly
labeled I could make the specificity one
reject everything saying nothing is an
instance true negatives goes to zero but
the sensitivity
sorry true negatives goes to one and I'm
in a great place there but my
sensitivity goes to zero I've got a
trade-off as I think about the machine
learning algorithm I using a my choice
of that classifier I'm going to see a
trade-off where I can increase
specificity at the cost of sensitivity
or vice versa and you'll see a nice
technique called
auro
see a receiver operator curb that gives
you a sense of how you want to deal with
that and with that we'll see you next
time we'll take your question offline if
you don't mind cuz I run over time but
we'll see you next time where Professor
Guttag will show you examples of this